[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 1er
mars
vendredi soir dernier le théâtre espace
coluche de plaisir à vibrer au rythme
des titres mythiques de queen retour sur
ce concert orchestré par coverqueen un
tribute band aux français et leur
musique rime avec robe couleur bonne
humeur et coups de gueule les ventes
passent sortent un nouvel album et était
sur la scène de la batterie ce week end
du 2 au 4 mars la communauté
d'agglomération de versailles va vivre
autour de la musique électro le cinéma
les yeux d'elsa de saint-cyr-l'ecole
diffusera à cette occasion interpelle à
5 5 5 5 un film composé des clips des
daft punk
il ya 25 ans disparaissait freddie
mercury le chanteur de l'un des plus
grands groupes de rock queen
on connaît tous au moins un titre mais
on nepeux à avoir pu les voir en concert
cover queen s'est lancé un défi leur
rendre hommage
le groupe fondé par deux frères dont
l'un est ibb les noix était sur la scène
du théâtre espace coluche de place hier
en vendredi dernier regardez c'est super
on est venu entre collègues on se
défoule et j'aimais bien les effets
spéciaux
j'aimais bien la voix du chanteur
c'était génial et les jeux de lumière
était extraordinaire
ça chantait ça dansait est difficile
pour les spectateurs du théâtre espace
coluche de rester à sa place sur scène
couverte queen tribute band français
enchaîne les titres du mythique groupe
britannique
il ya des morceaux on cherche à refaire
vraiment textuellement pas ce qui nous
plaisent parce que l'arrangement il est
fait comme ça on peut pas y toucher
et il ya d'autres morceaux où on
essayait un petit peu de réfléchir à ce
que ça aurait pu donner dans l'évolution
et de kuimba s'il aurait pu faire mieux
en live en 2017
[Musique]
bohemian rhapsody in medio gaga les fans
étaient servis avec effets
pyrotechniques qualité musicale et
prouesses vocales les marques de
fabrique des britanniques cover queen
est fondée par fred et alexandre caramia
le groupe enflamme les salles depuis dix
ans au début les gens se posent toujours
des questions alors est-ce qu'il va
chanter comme freddie mercury et est ce
que en fait on remplace pas queen on
remplace pas je remplace pas freddy
mercury
on essaye de rendre notre hommage à nous
et voilà le but que c'est que
il y à la puissance scénique quinn avait
que les gens participent qui est une
communion avec le public
si vous les avez ratés le prochain
rendez vous dans les yvelines ce sera le
13 mai au théâtre des arcades de but
parce que
mais
plus de trente ans de carrière et 12
albums dont le dernier est d'ailleurs
sorti ont fait briller les one pass le
groupe de punk rock français de retour
sur scène
il était à la batterie de guyancourt ce
week-end regarder un mois de tournée
déjà et un arrêt par guyancourt les
wampas mené depuis 34 ans par didier
wampas un rocker authentique étaient
présents à la batterie pour présenter
leur dernier album evangelisti c'était
un peu une légende des joutes qu'il a
gagné 5,6 fois c'est un bonhomme il fait
200 kilos et je teins visiblement
voulais pas qu'ils gagnent on l'a
éliminée injustement j'étais là quand
j'ai vu ça c'est la révolte et si du
et l'album evangelisti pour le venger
evangelisti ben je rencontre plein de
choses plein de petites anecdotes plein
de petites tranches de vivre là n'a pas
de grands messages jamais de gros
message simple un petit message qu'il
faut un grand message peut-être je ne
sais pas sortie le 12 février
évangéliste tissée l'histoire d'un
groupe dispersés aux quatre coins de la
france
un groupe hors du temps qui s'attaque
aux sujets quotidiens
je crée pas trop j'ai pris pas trop le x
e mail ou deux idées sur des carnets
mais pas grand chose et ce en studio que
j'ai créé presque toujours tout parce
que les chansons d'abord liée aux
béninois dans la matinée devant dieu et
après il faut faire des maîtres des
paroles des chansons en studio j'ai des
idées ou pas trouver des paroles là
dessus l'épaule de stations du tout non
aucune nostalgie à l'ancien on n'y a pas
de nostalgie déjà on essaie de faire
apprendre tous les nouveaux morceaux
bien les jouer sur scène
ces nouveaux tous les soirs sans attache
le groupe parcourt le pays pour assouvir
sa passion de la musique rock est les
wampas ne compte pas s'arrêter en si bon
chemin et poursuivront leur tournée
jusqu'à l'été
lyon
un mot de jazz à présent avec tv fil 78
vous pouvez dès aujourd'hui tenter de
remporter des places pour le concert de
hugh coltman
pour cela rien de plus simple direction
la page facebook de tv fil 78 laïque et
la publication du jeu concours et
surtout nommer la personne qui vous
accompagnera résultat du tirage au sort
le 14 mars et pour vous donner envie
un extrait oiseaux
[Musique]
very stream c'est beau
le cocker cinéma de la semaine est un
rendez vous musical bertrand pin et
d'elsa de saint-cyr-l'ecole vous la
présentez coûté le coup de coeur du
cinéma les yeux d'elsa cette semaine
c'est une projection de film et un
concert qui aura lieu le 4 mars
ici au cinéma les yeux d'elsa et ça se
passe dans le cadre du festival électro
chic versailles touch un festival
co-organisé par
la communauté d'agglomération de
versailles grand parc il ya plusieurs
événements du 2 au 4 mars sur autour de
versailles nous on accueille un
événement c'est à dire le concert d'un
groupe qui s'appelle anyways un groupe
de pop rock électro qui se produira sur
la scène derrière moi et juste après ce
concert on présentera un film qui est
rarement vu au cinéma qui s'appelle
interstella 5 5 5 5
the secretstory au star system
c'est un film un peu particulier parce
que il n'est composé que de clips de
l'album discovery de daft punk alors
pour ceux qui s'en souviennent daft punk
tout le monde le sait grand groupe
français d'électro en 2001 ils sortent
discovery qui est vendu par une série de
clips qui sont des clips fabriqué en
animation qu'une animation qui
ressemblent pour les plus anciens
d'entre nous le saurons à albator à ce
genre de dessin animé là des années 80
et puis alors que l'album est déjà vendu
tout à coup sort un film et on se rend
compte que tous ses clips sont quand on
les assemble dans un certain ordre sont
un long métrage une seule histoire de
1h20 et bien c'est ce long métrage qu'on
vous propose de voir ici le samedi 4
mars à partir de 20h30 au cinéma les
yeux d'elsa
n'hésitez pas à chercher les
renseignements il suffit de taper
festival électro chic et vous trouverez
tout ce qu'il vous faut
bertrand vient juste d'en parler le
festival électro chic alors des
animations mais aussi des concerts trois
soirées de musique électronique du 2 au
4 mars vous pourrez découvrir des
groupes en devenir peut-être lé
successeur dé versailles et daft punk ou
r les devis que moreau nous en dit un
peu plus il était l'invité de camille
lambert le vendredi 24 février qu'avec
une soirée 100% versailles le jeudi 2
avec notamment encore turzi et saint
michel qui sont voilà des produits de
versailles et ensuite donc le deuxième
jour on découvrait juarez qui est une
création spéciale pour l'événement
thylacine aussi qu est un jeune artiste
très prometteur et danger' et le
troisième soit il y aura agar agar
caspian foule d'abord agar agar
une jeune une jeune équipe voilà plus
très prometteuse et ensuite qu asus qui
est vraiment la figure une des figures
de la french touch des années 90 2000 et
pour en savoir un peu plus vous pouvez
retrouver l'intégralité de cet entretien
sur notre site internet tv fil 78 points
com rubrique émission 7,8 loisirs ont
passons maintenant à une page exposition
depuis le 24 février
jocelyne brise les haies et vagues
hodzic dialogue avec l'eau rare la
première pain dans un style contemporain
et détourne de célèbres tableaux la
seconde sculpte la question de
l'équilibré et leurs créations
s'entremêlent jusqu'au dimanche 5 mars
je m'approprie ces jeunes et je fais un
travail autour de ça qui accompagne
l'oeuvre connu jeu parfois je la
transforme je mets des pointes d'humour
j'essaye de faire parfois de l'ironie et
j'accompagne donc cette référence ça
peut être un comment on dire un extrait
de l'oeuvre pas forcément l'oeuvre en
entier un sujet en particulier aux la
sculpteuse je peux là
positionné différentes manières c'est à
dire qu'il n'ya pas il n'y a pas de
particulièrement fatalité il n'y a pas
de fall s'il n'y a pas de côté on peut
regarder on peut prendre la nana est
regardée de tous les côtés et on peut la
pause et aussi dans les différentes
manières des photos et noms des oeuvres
pour sa nouvelle exposition à l'occasion
de ses 20 ans le conservatoire des arts
de montigny le bretonneux présentent des
visages ceux des 580 personnes qui font
vivre la structure
ils sont professeurs ou élèves et le
trombinoscope est à découvrir jusqu'au 8
mars pour 8 mars prochain et que tu es
sophie poliakov la directrice du
conservatoire
nous avons voulu montrer le vrai visage
du conservatoire c'est à dire montrer un
peu quels sont les 580 personnes qui
viennent chaque semaine
prendre des cours donné de leur temps
essayez de hache à prendre petit à petit
la pédagogie et donc nous dispensons ici
on parle essentiellement des élèves donc
des enfants puisque les plus gênants 5
ans jusqu'aux plus âgés bien évidemment
les plus débutants et les confirmés
c'est à dire que certains sont là depuis
20 ans l'histoire de française s'exporte
à l'étranger et ça fonctionne c'est en
tout cas le constat que l'on peut faire
avec la fréquentation d'une exposition
qui s'est tenue à tokyo
marie-antoinette une reine à versailles
a accueilli plus de 420 mille visiteurs
en quatre mois c'était la première fois
qu'une exposition était consacrée à la
reine marie-antoinette hors de france
plus de 250 oeuvres issues des
collections du château et de prêts
publics et privés avaient fait le voyage
jusqu'au mori art gallery de tokyo les
visiteurs ont pu découvrir l'histoire de
la reine avec notamment la
reconstitution de pièces du château
[Musique]
et comme chaque semaine quelques rendez
vous à noter le premier il est à vivre
en famille animal c'était la merise de
trappes un voyage à travers des fables
pour petits et grands qui raconte le
cycle de la vie une réflexion autour de
la biodiversité et l'extinction des
espèces regardé plusieurs prévenus jean
vous les ombres il n'a pas voulu venir
mais d'abord vers l'autre mais si tu ne
vas plus en sortir qu elle pense que
trouillas maintenant et qu'est ce qu'on
fait on changeait rien au théâtre
national de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est une pièce qui se regardent et
s'écoute avec un casque audio à vivre là
aussi en famille chaque spectateur
choisit son histoire et vous suivrez
celle de nils un enfant touché par le
syndrome du repli sur soi regarder
dans mon lit sous les couvertures ça
vient juste de se produire mais par ont
pris la décision de se connecter à la
mémoire interne
il va entrer dans le système de sécurité
de nos cerveaux et s'introduire dans mes
souvenirs dans le droit de faire ça il
paraît que dans certaines situations
ça peut aider à régler des problèmes et
un dernier rendez vous avant de nous
quitter du 2 au 25 mars et le 19e caen
temps des poètes cette année les
afriques sont au coeur de cette nouvelle
édition rencontres lectures et
expositions toute la programmation est à
découvrir sur le site internet
deux kiosques voilà cette culture est
maintenant terminé merci de nous avoir
suivis et je vous dis à mettre 10
prochain
[Musique]